uh but we're gonna begin with the
historic and deadly rainfall now moving
deeper into the south after devastating
the dallas area that city had gotten no
rain none at all all summer and then it
fell all at once in buckets starting
sunday night eastern dallas saw nearly a
foot of rain in just 24 hours at least
one person has been confirmed killed so
far in these storms and omar villafranca
has made his way to dallas through those
flooded streets amid concerns the
flooding will continue to threaten the
region all week omar good morning
good morning i'm right here by the
trinity river in dallas and i got a few
pictures i want to show you so take a
look
just a few weeks ago the trinity river
was really just kind of a quiet stream
because of the drought and the triple
digit heat that was baking north texas
but take a look at this picture now the
river basin is filling up fast after
storms in north texas dumped just over
nine inches of rain in 24 hours
rescue crews were out in force in dallas
texas and the surrounding area carrying
children through several feet of flood
water while some residents attempted to
escape with what they could we saw some
cars get through it and then all of a
sudden we were stopped and then i see a
car just like floating towards the wall
and so oh shoot
others were pushing nearly submerged
cars out of flooded roadways
one local journalist helped a woman out
of her vehicle that was stuck in the
water i thought i was going to die
fort worth fire has responded to more
than 170 calls for rescue and that
number is expected to increase when the
flood waters receded dozens of abandoned
cars were revealed
crews pulled out this car that belonged
to a 60-year-old woman who was on her
way home from work she died after her
vehicle became submerged according to
dallas county officials
many residents across the region were
forced to wade through the waters in
their homes i hear like water rushing
that sounded like inside water so i was
like oh no further west dozens of people
evacuated an eastern arizona town when a
river overflowed and flooded its roads
and in utah the search continues for 29
year old jaetal agni-otri of tucson
arizona who was reported missing friday
while hiking zion national park after
the same storm system created raging
rivers of flash floods
yesterday's storms dropped the second
highest total of rain in a 24 hour
period now the good news here for north
texas this area will be able to dry out
but some of those storms as we're going
to show you on a radar
will be in the san antonio area into
houston and they are moving east into
louisiana and mississippi where those
folks could see several inches of rain
today
jamie buckle up omar thank you